[Music]
on this Monday night name-dropping
Washington's NFL team is being rebranded
ridding itself of a racist slur it's
time for a change I don't think it's
right to change it as Edmonton CFL team
tackles its own controversy the prime
minister's apology over the we charity
affair and I'm sincerely sorry why the
organization is now taking out ads with
one province about to start covering up
another is moving towards reopening up
as an American state starts shutting
down all because of Copan 19 and never
forgetting the victims of flight 752
she was so given the heartfelt plea from
their families
global national with Donna freezing
tonight
Robin Gil good evening and thank you for
joining us we begin tonight with a
dramatic change in the sports world
Washington's NFL team is punting its
name the Redskins critics have long
viewed it among the most racially
insensitive in North American sports for
years the team resisted pressure to toss
out the offensive line but a wave of
recent protests and calls to end
systemic racism led the Redskins to
become the latest symbol to fall and as
Eric Sorenson reports a major Canadian
team is also looking at a significant
switch fans may have meant no harm
but Redskins is a racist term and in
2020 demands to end systemic racism
finally forced Washington's NFL team to
abandon its name in a statement the team
announced we will be retiring the
Redskins name and logo and are working
to develop a new name this hall-of-famer
had been calling for it times have
changed and it's time for a change in
Washington for decades many have called
on the team's owner to drop the name Dan
Snyder unmoved once vowed he would never
change it but this year financial
pressure intensified from sponsors Fed
Ex Pepsi and Nike threatened to end
their lucrative relationships with the
team you look at the pressure being
applied from Nike who has taken the
Redskins name off of their online
database recent protests for racial
justice in the US and in Canada have
accelerated demands to remove racist
names and symbols and a Canadian team
may be next the edmonton eskimos this
month the team said past research found
no consensus on name change but would
ramp up engagement with the Inuit
communities new devotes member of
parliament mu malik kakak was blunt
tweeting the fact there was no consensus
means changed the name since then a
major team sponsor belairdirect has
stated to continue on with our
partnership we will need to see a
commitment to a name change the Eskimos
responded we are accelerating our review
and will update by the end of the month
one critic says teams are considering
dollars more than social justice this
just speaks to the fact
this is a financial move that the
industry is doing it because they have
to and not because they they want to
because they could have made the change
a long time ago other pro teams are
feeling the pressure the Chicago
Blackhawks the Atlanta Braves and their
fans tomahawk chop and baseball's
Cleveland Indians are looking to change
they say the name means no disrespect
but I don't think that's a good enough
answer today I think it's time to move
forward it may be long overdue but one
name change is underway and others may
follow Erik Sorensen Global News Toronto
Washington's NFL team is just the latest
about a pressure over offensive names
and logos as Eric mentioned Cleveland's
baseball team is considering a name
change after being called the Indians
since 1915 as for its logo the team only
stopped using the caricature of chief
wahoo and it's branding last year it
took decades of pressure for the MLB to
admit the cartoonish symbol of a Native
American was no longer appropriate when
the Philadelphia Warriors basketball
team moved to San Francisco in 1969 it
dropped the Native American logo in
favor of the Golden Gate Bridge and the
Baltimore bullets were named after a
nearby ammunition foundry that team then
renamed itself the Washington Wizards to
move away from violent overtones a may
of Kulpa from the prime minister today
Justin Trudeau addressed reporters for
the first time since his family's ties
to the we charity came to light the
charity was awarded a multi-million
dollar contract to administer the summer
student grants program Abigail Beeman
has more on the apology and the change
in tone from Ottawa weeks after
questions about we began the prime
minister now says he shouldn't have been
involved in cabinet conversations about
granting we a nearly billion dollar
contract I made a mistake and not
recusing myself immediately from the
discussions given our family's history
and I'm sincerely sorry his family's
history includes three hundred and
twelve thousand dollars paid to his
mother for speaking events over the past
four
years 40,000 for his brother and a $1400
payment for his wife in 2012 Monday
afternoon the finance minister tweeted
an apology for not recusing himself to
his daughter works for the we
organisation the Prime Minister was not
clear about whether he knew his family
was paid
I knew that my brother and and my mother
work as professional public speakers and
it is not surprising to me that they got
paid by we but I did not know the
details and as I said I should have
known the details if he is in fact sorry
that you can demonstrate that to
Canadians by not invoking cabinet
confidence appearing and testifying at
committee and releasing all documents
and the contract itself we're also
hearing more from the founders of we
mark and Craig Kielburger took out
full-page newspaper ads and posted this
statement on their website they say
they've made mistakes which they
sincerely regret and promised to have
more to say in the coming days but it's
a controlled narrative told on their
terms they've so far declined our
interview request the statement says we
hasn't profited from the government
contract in any way or accepted any
reimbursement for work to establish the
program and the brothers point out they
have worked with federal and provincial
governments of many stripes the
organisation democracy watch is calling
for an extended investigation by the
ethics commissioner and has more
questions for the RCMP anyone in the
Prime Minister's Office or anyone asking
his behalf or the Prime Minister himself
intervene in the contracting process in
order to essentially get in favor of a
sole source contract from each charity
the office of the ethics commissioner
tells us he expects to decide this week
whether to expand that investigation the
prime minister meanwhile says he's
particularly sorry that young people
will have to wait longer for
opportunities according to we in the
first week after the programme launched
there were 35,000 applicants Abigail
Beeman Global News Ottawa the prime
minister confirmed today the federal
government will be extending its
programme to subsidize wages for
companies hit hard by the Cova 19
pandemic this week
we'll be announcing
an extension to the wage subsidy program
until December to give greater certainty
and support to businesses as we restart
the economy the program covers 75% of
wages up to a weekly maximum of eight
hundred and forty seven dollars for
workers at eligible companies and
nonprofit organizations as of July 6 the
program has given over 18 billion
dollars to more than two hundred and
fifty two thousand companies across the
country the prime minister did not say
today how the government plans to revamp
eligibility rules
critics claim the guidelines stopped
some employers from getting the aid they
need much of Ontario will move into the
next fav phase of its reopening plan
this week but not the most heavily
populated part of the province 24
regions will move into phase 3 on Friday
but the Greater Toronto Area and
surrounding regions as well as the
Windsor sx area will have to wait a bit
longer that's because they moved into
phase 2 later phase 3 allows 99% of
businesses to reopen we won't stop until
we get every person in Ontario until we
get every worker in Ontario back to work
and back on their feet in phase 3 indoor
dining will finally be allowed with
limits on capacity the same goes for
gyms bars and nightclubs but without the
dancing movie theatres and live
performances are getting the green light
also with caps on attendance up to 50
people will be able to gather in doors a
hundred people outdoors and physical
distancing measures will need to be in
place anyone entering an indoor public
space in Quebec will soon need to put on
a mask I ask all Quebecers to wear a
mask in shops and in public
transportation dicovered 19 virus is
really dangerous it's easy to catch when
you're close to another person
Lego says it will be mandatory for
anyone over the age of 12 to wear face
masks inside shops businesses and other
enclosed places effective Saturday the
only exception will be for people with
specific medical conditions the rule
will also apply to people inside
restaurants but only when customers are
walking around not while sitting at a
table as of now it will be on the
businesses to enforce the order and they
could be fined between $400 to as much
as six thousand dollars if they fail to
do so individuals who aren't abiding by
the rule could begin facing penalties at
the start of next month
south-of-the-border outbreaks are
getting so bad the most populated state
in the u.s. California is shutting
things down again and it's a perilous
situation right across the country
yesterday alone there were nearly 58
thousand new cases in the US and
according to the New York Times
that's a 51 percent increase in the
number of new cases from two weeks
earlier but with novel coronavirus cases
surging president Donald Trump is
attacking one of the nation's top
doctors rather than the virus itself
Jaxon prosecco reports Florida is now
the epicenter of the pandemic in the
u.s. today Miami has a higher rate of
Cova at 19 cases per capita than New
York City did at its peak deaths are
rising here and in a majority of states
in Texas they're building temporary
morgues California took the drastic step
of closing all indoor venues including
restaurants and bars this is a new
statewide action effective today with
the certainty of more grim days ahead
the White House has adopted a new
coronavirus strategy discredit the
messenger by going after the country's
top infectious disease specialist dr.
Anthony foul gee this is a really
serious problem it is truly historic we
haven't even begun to see the end of it
yet pouchy has become more vocal in
recent weeks the Trump administration
has responded by undermining his
credibility well I think we are in a
good place I disagree with him you know
dr. Feld she said don't wear masks and
now he says were the White House now
accuses foul G of not being dire enough
in his initial warnings I respect dr.
Fauci a lot but dr. Fauci is not 100%
right ouchies messages have followed the
ever-evolving science from the outset he
warned the situation could always change
67% of Americans say they try
doctor foul chief or accurate
information about the pandemic compared
to just 26% who say they trust President
Trump Trump also retweeted a former game
show host to accuse the US Centers for
Disease Control of lying about the virus
claiming it's all about the election
what are the consequences of
discrediting scientists at a point like
this when we discredit scientists we
undercut our own ability to be able to
deal with the virus this should not be
political science facts data that's not
political just like the virus is not
political tonight there are signs that
the White House may not be able to
ignore the science or the reality much
longer
California's two largest school
districts now say they will not be able
to resume in-person lessons as planned
this fall and in Miami a top doctor
there said the situation as it stands
right now is comparable to Wuhan China
in March Robin
Jackson prosecco in Washington there's a
dire warning from the World Health
Organization that people are getting
mixed messages about Kovan 19 and it's
undermining efforts to stop further
infections the organization's
director-general says the virus is
raging around the world and will get
worse if countries don't stick to strict
health care precautions let me be blunt
too many countries are headed in the
wrong direction
the virus remains public enemy number
one but the actions of many governments
and people do not reflect of this the
WTO says there will be no return to the
old normal for the foreseeable future
but there are ways to control the
disease without shutting down our lives
they include reducing fatality and
suppressing transmission and empowering
communities to take their own measures
there are more than 13 million cases of
Cova 19 around the world and more than
half a million people have died a
grieving mother at a growing memorial
for her two little girls coming up her
first public comments as the search for
the children's father ramps up Plus
remembering Kelly Preston
John Travolta's tribute to his late wife
tonight the mother of two girls found
dead in Quebec Saturday is sharing the
pain that no parent should ever have to
bear and manhunt is intensifying for the
girl's father Martin Karp Ranchi police
have brought in k9 units and a thermal
detection plane to try and track him
down and as Mike Armstrong reports they
do have some leads with unmistakable and
unimaginable pain a milena Mia Monday
afternoon broke her silence just two
days after her daughter's were found
dead she visited the growing memorial in
their memory and then flanked by family
and loved ones stepped to the
microphones lumière thanked police for
their work in the public for its support
and ask that her daughter's be her stars
in the night to light her way through
the page
there have been no sightings or contact
with methank upon t-84 days the only
clues police have were found by the
bodies of honey and exactly what that
was
police aren't saying admitting only it
is the reason they're still searching in
the same area the last elements that we
found yesterday lead us to think that
this is the best place that maybe we
could find my think about see now other
than actually finding him the big
question is what happened cap bossy and
Lemire separated years ago the breakup
wasn't recent and just this spring
things appear to have been okay this is
a video calf Patsy and her maid for
their Scout Troop when meetings were
canceled due to kovat 19 novice says to
her friends keep hoping for a camping
trip this summer
now last Wednesday night cap on SIA had
his daughters the mystery started when
his car was found after what police
described as a serious one vehicle
accident no one was found inside since
then police have been searching a sector
just to the east it was in that area
that the girls bodies were found
autopsies are being done but police
aren't sharing the details they do
however say it appears cap Patsy was
injured in the car accident between that
the heat and the thick brush they say
cash party may not be on the run he may
be dead all those factors would the time
passing by can let us think that maybe
isn't alive anymore one thing that has
hindered the search is the public
there have been unfounded rumors of
arrests and people showing up in the
forest to participate in the search the
story has gripped the province but
police are asking people to stay away
and follow only official sources
my carbs on global news Montreal tragedy
and an eerie coincidence still ahead the
search ends for a Glee star
the youngest daughter of anti-apartheid
leaders Nelson and Winnie Mandela has
died Zindzi Mandela died today in
Denmark she was serving as South
Africa's ambassador to the Nordic
country she rose to prominence in 1985
when she read her father's letter
rejecting the white minority
government's offer to release Nelson
Mandela from prison if he denounced
violence perpetrated by the African
National Congress Mandela continued the
fight against racism after the deaths of
her father and mother she was 59
Hollywood actor Kelly Preston has passed
away after a two-year battle with breast
cancer I'm too strong for you lose her
Preston was known for her energetic
roles in movies like Jerry Maguire twins
and mischief she was also the wife of
Hollywood star John Travolta who in an
Instagram post said Preston fought a
courageous fight with the love and
support of so many she was 57 in
California the search for missing actor
Naya Rivera has reached a grim
conclusion search teams recovered
Rivera's body from a lake this morning
the Glee star vanished during an outing
last week with her four-year-old son he
was found alone on a rented boat Rivera
was best known for her role as Santana
Lopez on the TV show today is also the
seventh anniversary of the death of her
Glee co-star Cory Monteith up next seven
months since the tragedy of flight 752
and families are still waiting for
justice
it's been just over six months since the
downing of Ukraine flight 752 on 176
people on board including 55 Canadian
citizens and 30 permanent residents died
the jet was shot down by Iran's military
and the investigation has made little
progress next week Iran is expected to
send the planes black boxes to Paris our
Europe bureau chief crystal command
Singh has more on the next step and a
plea from the victim's families shadi is
remembered as the strong one a sister
with a big heart and a daughter who
chased down her dreams of continuing her
education in Canada
she was so giving she was ready to help
all of her family members all of her
friends shadi means happiness and joy in
Farsi that's exactly what was ripped
from the families of the 176 people
killed on flight 752 the Ukrainian
Airlines plane was shot down in January
just after takeoff human error
according to Iran I don't feel this pain
is healing at all I feel in the last six
months it has even deepened itself
within me this sadness within days of
the plane being shot down Iran pledged
to send the black boxes away so that
they could be analyzed potentially in
France
that never happened Tehran then said
there was no point because they were so
badly damaged
well now Canadian officials have
confirmed that the black boxes will be
sent to Paris the week of the 20th
families wrong answers Canada along with
all of the grieving Nations vowed to get
justice for the victims members of the
Transportation Safety Board will be
present in Paris to observe the work on
the flight data recorders a government
spokesperson says families are being
kept informed using a special website
the families created their own website
fearing people have forgotten about the
tragedy
shelli's brothers say the Canadian
government has been helpful they're
being quite generously offering their
support but having said that we haven't
achieved anything the first step is
generally decoding the black boxes that
still days away if it happens at all
there are too many lines coming off too
many conspiracy theories our hearts
paint more and more besides learning
what's on the flight data recorders the
families want to know why the airspace
was open during hostile times and if
it's because the government didn't want
to lose out on the thousands of dollars
it makes allowing commercial flights in
its airspace crystal dancing global news
London and that's global national for
this Monday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is bright Sand Lake in
Saskatchewan we would love to see your
corner of this country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at global
national comm thank you for watching
Donna freeze and we'll be back here
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]